Roswell Bigfoot's oh okay
shape-shifting lizards interesting
conspiracy theories do you require a
wild imaginative leap I think we can
explain it in a scientific way so why do
we believe some more ridiculous way yes
and of course they spread much more than
we know with the advent of social media
what can you trust the term conspiracy
theory refers to explanations according
to which events in the world are caused
by an evil plan plotted in secret by a
small group of powerful individuals some
decades ago there was this tendency to
conceive conspiracy beliefs as
pathological but psychologists have
shifted this they nowadays believe
normal functions of our mind explains
why people believe in conspiracy theory
[Music]
the defining features of the conspiracy
theory are a conspirator the
conspiratorial plan the sinister plan
that they're trying to bring about and
the means of mass manipulation by which
the conspirator is keeping the planet
secret sometimes the conspirator will be
defined in terms of a concrete body with
an identifiable membership the
Illuminati or the Freemasons Jews and
more recently on things like the
Bilderberg Group Skull and Bones Society
and various other secret societies
however very often the conspirator will
be defined in much vaguer terms the big
farmer the military-industrial complex
global elites and so on so they're
always balancing between the need to
define the enemy and the need to accept
that the enemy is always going to be
shady secret and so on conspiracy
theorists will often argue that if you
destroy a group of powerful people in
the world you will not destroy the
conspiracy because the plan is the key
thing very often that plan is going to
involve world domination but if one
looks at the level of cover-up that will
be required in order to keep all these
things secret it necessitates having
somebody who is actually in control of
everything
much of the conspiracist writing will
involve trying to analyze what
strategies and what power the
conspirators have to keep their sinister
plan or their identity hidden very often
their manipulations come from the
plausible things like science government
media ownership to the ludicrous
paranormal manipulation use of occult
powers manipulation of brainwaves
[Music]
conspiracy believers I think they did
genuinely believing in the theories and
the they really strive for the truth it
may seem naive but there is this human
tendency to underestimate the role that
chance alone can play in events that
occur this belief that the world is
ultimately controllable and that is a
very kind of powerful driver of
conspiracy beliefs in moments of crisis
where there is almost like a vacuum in
explanation we see this more social
function of conspiracy beliefs and the
fact that people believing them or not
as being part of their social identity
the stereotype is there in their cellar
on the internet looking for the most
recent conspiracy theory but most people
are neither believers no skeptics but
fall somewhere in the middle and for me
the key question is not what
differentiates the hard believers from
the hard skeptics but how do we
interpret that section of the population
in the middle conspiracy theories can be
dangerous for society people who believe
that vaccines like cause autism and
avoid vaccinating their children put
them in danger
a thorough thinking person could debunk
one argument at a time but could not
debunk all their arguments sinister
conspiracy theories like the
anti-semitic conspiracy theories of the
early 20th century or if you talk
outlandish in terms of David Ickes alien
lizards the fundamental error is always
the same they're all based on the
fundamentally flawed assumption about
how the world works and I think that if
one makes people more aware of what
conspiracy theories are it enables them
when they see a conspiracy theory to see
it for what it is
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon